khaled maupin journaliste politique rt
américain c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir calais
maupin merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors que recherche le
gouvernement américain en tentant
d'imposer la présence des élèves en
cours
pour donald trump c'est une façon
d'essayer de forcer lui la relance de
l'économie
forcer les élèves à retourner à l'école
les parents à revenir au travail
les enseignants également devront se
rendre en cours donc c'est une façon de
pousser la rouverture de l'économie et
c'est une idée que soutiennent la
plupart des républicains beaucoup de
petits propriétaires d'entreprises sont
des soutiens importants pour donald
trump et ils ont l'impression que amazon
bénéficient de cette pandémie alors même
que les petites entreprises en souffrent
donc de notre homme essaye de relancer
toute l'économie et pas seulement les
écoles alors pour pouvoir rester le
gouvernement tram demandé aux étudiants
de se faire transférer dans des
établissements qui reprendront
l'enseignement présentiel mais c'est
très compliqué à mettre en oeuvre pour
ses étudiants il me dit on nous fait
donald trump met une pression très forte
sur le système universitaire il veut que
les universités rendre et il fait tout
son possible pour leur rendre la vie
difficile si elle souhaite rester fermés
ou la ministre de l'éducation américaine
n'a souhaité beauce est riche à des
contacts avec les milieux militaires et
une défend la privatisation et
souhaiterait qu'ils le plus de
privatisations dans le système de
l'éducation et essaye également de
mettre une pression sur le système
universitaire public américain alors
dans ce bras de fer
révoqué les visas des étudiants
étrangers ça fait partie de sa manière
de mettre la pression est là les
autorités les universités plus tôt avec
elles s'opposent carrément en justice
l'institut de technologie du michigan et
l'université de harvard porte plainte
contre donald trump parce qu'il menace
de leur retirer leurs étudiants
internationaux
s'il ne réouvrira pas les universités
ont un train peut souligner à un sujet
que beaucoup de personnes ont déjà
évoqué l'occasion notamment par exemple
steve banane le système des universités
américaines travaillent au niveau
international plutôt qu'au niveau
américain uniquement l'un des grands
stratégiste américain de la gamme froide
a dit que les personnes du monde entier
se rendait aux universités américaines
et que cela participait de l'influencé
américaine le système universitaire
américain ne sert pas uniquement la
population nationale les seuils de
courtiser la population nationale est de
rassembler les plus grands ça vaut
internationale afin de développer leur
loyauté envers les idéaux occidentaux
afin de faire d'eux des sympathisants du
des états unis de retour dans leur pays
d'origine
certaines personnes plus centré sur
l'économie nationaliste pense que c'est
une trahison et que les universités
devraient servir uniquement les états
unis donc ton à 30 ces pressions sur
l'université et fait de ces étudiants
internationaux des otages et souligne
ainsi le nombre des vieux internationaux
dans ces universités alors de son côté
lui donald trump il dit il dénonce à une
utilisation politique des universités
pour quelles raisons
les universités aux états unis sont
plutôt d'inspiration de gauche on a des
cours sur l'étude des idées de genre sur
les idées de race on parle par exemple
du privilège blanc et certains
professeurs enseignent les parties les
plus laides de l'histoire des états unis
comme l' esclavage par exemple un camp
conservateur néo conservateurs
américains a lancé une campagne contre
certains enseignants qu'ils
considéraient comme étant communiste
anti américain il ya vraiment une
campagne de très longue haleine contre
la gauche dans les universités et donald
trump s'inscrit dans ce courant ainsi
que beaucoup de ses électeurs des
américains des régions les plus
conservatrices des états unis voient
leurs enfants leur revenir avec des
idées socialistes de gauche après les
avoir envoyées à université et considère
que ce ne sont plus donc la même
personne et ne souhaite pas cela est ce
que cette nouvelle sortie du président
américain il peut avoir selon vous un
poids dans la balance électorale
tout à fait le système des universités
est très important aux états unis on
parle d'inflation de l'éducation il ya
beaucoup de plus de personnes diplômées
aujourd'hui qu'auparavant et la dette
des étudiants est également très
importante l'éducation aux états unis
n'est pas gratuite comme dans d'autres
pays
il faut s'endetter ou alors payer
directement et le système universitaire
et donc une partie très importante de
l'économie américaine la tête des
étudiants est un acteur très important
économiquement parlant
beaucoup de familles ont un enfant à
l'université beaucoup d'adultes prennent
des cours du soir afin d'obtenir un
diplôme ou un autre diplôme parce que
dans la trame s'attaque aux universités
il pourrait causer des remous très
larges en tous cas jusqu'à novembre
merci calastreng parents d'avoir été
avec nous pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir
merci à vous